The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --And go on with
lectures 8 to 10.
First I want to briefly
review what we said
about measurable functions.
Again, I encourage you if you
hate this material and you
think it's only for
mathematicians,
please let me know.
I don't know whether it's
appropriate to cover it in
this class either.
I think it probably is because
you need to know a little more
mathematics when you deal with
these Fourier transforms and
Fourier series.
When you're dealing with
communication theory, then you
need to know for signal
processing
and things like that.
When you get into learning a
little more, my sense at this
point is it's much easier to
learn a good deal more than it
is to learn just a little bit
more, because a little bit
more you're always faced with
all of these questions of what
does this really mean.
It turns out that if you put
just a little bit of measure
theory into your thinking, it
makes all these problems very
much simpler.
So you remember we talked about
what a measurable set
was last time.
What a measurable set is, is a
set which you can essentially
break up into a countable
union of intervals, and
something which is bounded by
a countble set of intervals
which have arbitrarily
small measure.
So you can take all of these
sets of zero measure --
countable sets, cantor sets, all
of these things, and you
can just throw all of those
out from consideration.
That's what makes measure theory
useful and interesting
and what simplifies things.
So we then said that a function
is measurable if each
of these sets here -- if the
set of times for which a is
less than or equal to u of t is
less than or equal to b --
these things are these
level sets here.
It's a set of values, t, along
this axis in which the
function is nailed between any
two of these points here.
For a function to be measurable,
all of these sets
in here have to be measurable.
We haven't given you any
examples of sets which are not
measurable, and therefore, we
haven't given you any examples
of functions which are
not measurable.
It's very, very difficult to
construct such functions, and
since it's so difficult to
construct them, it's easier to
just say that all of the
functions we can think of are
measurable.
That includes an awful lot more
functions than you ever
deal with in engineering.
If you ever make a serious
mistake in your engineering
work because of thinking that a
function is measurable when
it's not measurable, I
will give you $1,000.
I make that promise that you
because I don't think it's
ever happened in history, I
don't think it ever will
happen in history, and that's
just how sure I am of it.
Unless you try to deliberately
make such a mistake in order
to collect $1,000.
Of course, that's not fair.
Then we said the way we define
this approximation to the
integral, namely, we always
defined it from underneath,
and therefore, if we started to
take these intervals here
with epsilon and split them in
half, the thing that happens
is you always get extra
components put in.
So that as you make the scaling
finer and finer, what
happens is the approximation
into the integral gets larger
and larger.
Because of that, if you're
dealing with a non-negative
function, the only two things
that can happen, as you go to
the limit of finer and finer
scaling, is one, you come to a
finite limit, and two, you come
to an infinite limit.
Nothing else can happen.
You see that's remarkably simple
as mathematics go.
This is dealing with all of
these functions you can ever
think of, and those are the
only two things that can
happen here.
So then we went on to say that
a function as L1, if it's
measurable, and if the integral
of its magnitude is
less than infinity, and
so far we're still
talking about real functions.
If u of t is L1, then you can
take the integral of u of t
and you can split it
up into two things.
You can split it up into the set
of times over which u of t
is positive, and the
set of times over
which u of t is negative.
The set of times over which u of
t is equal to zero doesn't
contribute to the integral
at all so you can
forget about that.
This is well-defined as the
function is measurable.
What's now happening is that
if the integral of this
magnitude is less than infinity,
then both this has
to be less than infinity, and
this has to be less than
infinity, which says that so
long as you're dealing with L1
functions, you never have to
worry about this nasty
situation where the negative
part of the function is
infinite, the positive part of
the function is infinite, and
therefore, the difference, plus
infinity, minus infinity
doesn't make any sense at all.
And instead of having an
integral which is infinite or
finite, you have a function
which might just be undefined
completely.
Well this says that if the
function is L1, you can't ever
have any problem with integrals
of this sort thing
being undefined.
So, and in fact, u of t is
always integral and has a
finite value in this case.
Now, we say that a complex
function is measurable if both
the real part is measurable
and the imaginary part is
measurable.
Therefore, you don't have to
worry about complex functions
as really being any more than
twice as complicated as real
functions, and conceptually
they aren't any more
complicated at all because you
just treat them as two
separate functions, and
everything you know about real
functions you now know about
complex functions.
Now, as far as Fourier theory
is concerned --
Fourier series, Fourier
integrals, discrete time,
Fourier transforms -- all of
these things, if u of t is an
L1 function, then u of t times e
to the 2 pi ft has to be L1,
and this has to be true for
all possible values of f.
Why is that?
Well, it's just that the
absolute value of u of t for
any given t, is exactly the same
as the absolute value of
u of t times e to
the 2 pi i ft.
Namely, this is a quantity whose
magnitude is always 1,
and therefore, this quantity,
this magnitude is equal to
this magnitude.
Therefore, when you integrate
this magnitude, you get the
same thing as when you integrate
this magnitude.
So, there's no problem here.
So what that says, using this
idea, too, of positive and
negative parts, it says that the
integral of u of t times e
to the 2 pi i ft dt has to
exist for all real f.
That covers Fourier series
and Fourier integral.
We haven't talked about the
Fourier integral yet, but it
says that just by defining u of
t to be L1, you avoid all
of these problems of when these
Fourier integrals exist
and when they don't exist.
They always exist.
So let's talk about the Fourier
transform then since
we're backing into this
slowly anyway.
What you've learned in probably
two or three classes
by now is that the Fourier
transform is
defined in this way.
Namely, the transform, a
function of frequency, u hat
of f, we use hats here instead
of capital letters because we
like to use capital letters
for random variables.
So that this transform here
is the integral from minus
infinity to infinity of the
original function, we start
with u of t times e to the
minus 2 pi ift dt.
Now, what's the nice
part about this?
The nice part about this is that
if u of t is L1, then in
fact this Fourier transform
has to exist everywhere.
Namely, what you've learned
before in all of these classes
says essentially that if these
functions are well-behaved
then these transforms exist.
What you've learned about
well-behaved is completely
circular, namely, a function
is well-behaved if the
transform exists, and the
transform exists if the
function is well-behaved.
You have no idea of what kinds
of functions the Fourier
transform exists and
what kinds of
functions it doesn't exist.
There's another thing buried
in here, in this transform
relationship.
Namely, the first thing is we're
trying to define the
transform function of frequency
in terms of the
function of time.
Well and good.
Then we try to define a function
of time in terms of a
function of frequency.
What's hidden here is if you
start with u of t, you then
get a function of frequency,
and this sort of implicitly
says that you get back
again the same
thing you started with.
That, in fact, is the most
ticklish part of all of this.
So that if we start with an L1
function u of t, we wind up
with a Fourier transform,
u hat of f.
Then u hat of f goes in here.
We hope we might get back
the sum transform here.
The nasty thing, and one of the
reasons we're going to get
away from L1 in just a minute,
is that if a function is L1,
it's Fourier transform is
not necessarily L1.
What that means is that you
have to learn all of this
stuff about L1 functions, and
then as soon as you take the
Fourier transform, bingo, it's
all gone up in a lot of smoke,
and you have to start all over
again saying something about
what properties the transform
might have.
But anyway, it's nice to start
with because when u of t is
L1, we know that this function
actually exists.
It actually exists as
a complex number.
It exists as a complex
number for every
possible real f here.
Namely, there aren't any if,
and's, but's or maybe's here,
there's nothing like L2
convergence that we were
talking about a little
bit before.
This just exists, period.
There's something more here,
that if this is L1, this not
only exists but it's also a
continuous function, and those
don't prove that.
If you've taken a course in
analysis and you know what a
complex function is and you're
quite patient, you can sit
down and actually show
this yourselves, but
it's a bit of a pain.
So for a well-behaved function,
the first integral
exists for all f, the second
exists for all t, and results
in the original u of t.
But then more specifically,
if u of t is L1, the first
integral exists for all f and
it's a continuous function.
It's also a bounded function, as
we'll see in a little bit.
If u hat of f is L1, the second
integral exists for all
t, and u of t is continuous.
Therefore, if you assume at
the output at the onset of
things that both this is
L1 and this is L1, then
everything is also continuous
and you have a very nice
theory, which doesn't apply to
too many of the things that
you're interested in.
And I'll explain why
in a little bit.
Anyway, for these well-behaved
functions, we have all of
these relationships that I'm
sure you've learned in
whatever linear systems
course you've taken.
Since you should know all of
these things, I just want to
briefly talk about them I mean
this linearity idea is
something you would
just use without
thinking about it, I think.
In other words, if you'd never
learned this and you were
trying to work out a problem you
would just use it anyway,
because anything respectable has
to have -- well, anything
respectable, again,
means anything
which has this property.
This conjugate property you can
derive that easily from
the Fourier transform
relationships also, if you
have a well-behaved function.
This quantity here, this
duality, is particularly
interesting because it isn't
really duality, it's something
called hermitian duality.
You start out with this formula
here to go to there
and you use almost the same
formula to get back again.
The only difference is instead
of a minus 2 pi ift, you have
a plus 2 pi ift.
In other words, this is the
conjugate of this, which is
why this is called hermitian
duality.
But aside from that, everything
you learn about the
Fourier transform, you also
automatically know about the
inverse Fourier transform for
these well-behaved functions.
Otherwise you don't know whether
the other one exists
or not, and we'll certainly
get into that.
So, the duality is expressed
this way, the Fourier
transform of, bleah.
If you take a function, u of
t, and regard that as a
Fourier transform, then --
I always have trouble
saying this.
If you take a function, u of t,
and then you regard that as
a function of frequency --
OK, that's this -- and then you
regard it as a function of
minus frequency, namely, you
substitute minus f for t in
whatever time function
you start with.
You start with a time function u
of t, you substitute minus f
for t, which gives you a
function of frequency.
The inverse Fourier transform
of that is what you get by
taking the Fourier transform
of u of t, and then
substituting t for f in it.
It's much harder to
say it than to do.
This time shift, you've
all seen that.
If you shift a function in
time, the only thing that
happens is you get this
rotating term in it.
Same thing for a frequency
shift.
You want to have an interesting
exercise, take
time shift plus duality and
derive the scaling and
frequency from it -- it has to
work, and of course, it does.
Scaling --
there's this relationship
here.
This one is always
a funny one.
It's a little strange because
when you scale here, it's not
too surprising that when you
take a function and you squash
it down that the Fourier
transform
gets squashed upwards.
Because in a sense what you're
doing when you squash a
function down you're making
everything happen faster than
it did before, which means that
all the frequencies in it
are going to get higher
than they are before.
But also when you squash it
down, the amount of energy in
the function is going
to go down.
One of the most important
properties that we're going to
find and what you ought to know
already is that when you
take the energy in a function,
you get the same answer as you
get when you take the energy
in the Fourier transform.
Namely, you integrate u of f
squared over frequency and you
get the same as if you
integrate u of t
squared over time.
That's an important check
that you use on
all sorts of things.
The thing that happens now then
when you're scaling is
when you scale a function, u
of t, you bring it down and
you spread it out when
you bring it down.
The frequency function goes up
so the energy in the time
function goes down, the energy
in the frequency function goes
up, and you need something in
order to keep the energy
relationship working properly.
This is what you need.
Actually, if you derive
this, the t
just falls out naturally.
So we get the same thing if we
do scaling and frequency.
I don't think I put that
down but it's the same
relationship.
There's differentiation.
Differentiation we won't talk
about or use it a whole lot.
All of these things turn out
to be remarkably robust.
When you're dealing with L1
functions or L2 functions and
you scale them or you shift
them or do any of those
things, if they're L1, they're
still L1 after you're through,
if they're L2, they're L2
after you're through.
If you differentiate
a function, all
those properties change.
You can't be sure of
anything anymore.
There's convolution, which I'm
sure you've derived many
times, and which one of the
exercises derives again.
There's correlation, and what
this sort of relationship says
is taking products at the
frequency domain is the same
as going through this
convolution relationship and
the time domain.
Of course, there's a dual
relation to that, which you
don't use very often but
it still exists.
Correlation is you actually get
correlation by using one
of the conjugate properties on
the convolution and I'm sure
you've all seen that.
That's something you should
all have been using and
familiar with for a long time.
Two special cases of the Fourier
transform is that u of
zero is what happens when you
take the Fourier transform and
you evaluate it at
t equals zero.
You get u of zero is just the
integral of u hat of f.
u hat of zero is just the
integral of u of t.
What do you use these for?
Well the thing I use them for
is this half the time when
you're working out a problem
it's obvious by inspection
what this integral is or it's
obvious by inspection what
this integral is, and by doing
that you can check whether you
have all the constants
right in the
transform that you've taken.
I don't know anybody who can
take Fourier transforms
without getting at least one
constant wrong at least half
the time they do it.
I probably get one constant
wrong about three-quarters of
the time that I do it, and I'm
sure I'll do it here in class
a number of times.
I hope you find it, but it's one
of these things we all do.
This is one of the best ways
of finding out what you've
done and going back
and checking it.
Parseval's Theorem, Parseval's
Theorem is really just this
convolution equation which
we're applying
at tau equals zero.
You take the convolution, you
apply it at tau equals zero
and what do you get?
You get the integral of u of t
times some other conjugate --
the conjugate of the other
function is equal to the
integral of u hat of
f times the complex
conjugate of v of f.
Much more important than this
is what happens if v happens
to be the same as u, and that
gives you the energy equation
here, which is what I
was talking about.
It says the integral in a
function you can find it two
ways, either by looking
at it in time or by
looking at it in frequency.
I urge you to always think
about doing this whenever
you're working problems, because
often the Fourier
integral it's very easy to find
the integral and the and
the time function is
very difficult.
A good example of this
is sinc functions
and rectangular functions.
Anybody can take a rectangular
function, square it and
integrate it.
It takes a good deal of skill
if you don't use this
relationship to take a sinc
function, to square it and to
integrate it.
You can do it if you're skillful
at integration, you
might regard it as a challenge,
but after you get
done you realize that you've
really wasted a lot of time
because this is the right
way of doing it here.
Now, as I mentioned before,
it's starting to look like
Fourier series and Fourier
integrals are much nicer when
you have L1 functions, and they
are, but L1 functions are
not terribly useful
as far as most
communication functions go.
In other words, not enough
functions are L1 to provide
suitable models for the
communication systems that we
want to look at.
In fact, most of the models that
we're going to look at,
the functions that we're dealing
with are L2 functions.
One of the reasons for this is
this sinc function, sine x
over x function is not L1.
A sinc function just goes down
as 1 over t, and since it goes
down as 1 over t, you take the
absolute value of it and you
integrate 1 over t and what do
you get when you integrate it
from minus infinity
to infinity.
A function that's 1 over t,
well, if you really want to go
through the trouble of
integrating it, you can
integrate it over limits and you
get limits where you have
to evaluate the limits on
a logarithmic function.
When you get all done
with that you
get an infinite value.
And you can see this.
You could take 1 over t and you
just look at it, as you go
further and further out it just
gets bigger and bigger
without limit.
So, sinc t is not L1.
Sinc function is a function
we'd like to use.
Any function with a
discontinuity can't be the
Fourier transform of
any L1 function.
In other words, we said that
if you take the Fourier
transform of an L1 function, one
of the nice things about
it is you get a continuous
function.
One of the nasty things
about it is you get
a continuous function.
Since you get a continuous
function it says that any time
you want to deal with transforms
which are not
continuous, you can't be talking
about time functions
which are L1.
One of the frequency functions
we want to look at a great
deal is a frequency function
corresponding to a
band-limited function.
When you take a band-limited
function you just chop it off
at some frequency, and usually
when you chop it off, you chop
it off and get a
discontinuity.
When you chop it off and get a
discountinuity, bingo, the
time function you're dealing
with cannot be L1.
It has to dribble away
much too slowly as
time goes to infinity.
That's an extraordinarily
important thing to remember.
Any time you get a function
which is discontinuous in the
frequency domain, the function
cannot go to zero any faster
in a time domain than 1 over
t and vice versa in the
frequency domain.
L1 functions sometimes
have infinite energy.
In other words, sinc
t is not L1 --
well, that's not a good example
because that's not L1,
and it also has infinite energy,
but you can just as
easily find functions which drop
off a little more slowly
than sinc t, and which
have infinite
energy because they--.
Excuse me.
Sometimes you have functions
which go off to infinity too
fast as you approach time equals
zero, things which are
a little bit like impulses
but not really.
Impulses are awful and we'll
talk about them in a minute,
because they don't have finite
energy as we said before.
We have functions which just
slowly go off to infinity and
they are L2 but they
aren't L1.
Why do we care about those
weird functions?
We care about them, as I said
before, because we would like
to be able to make statements
which are simple which we can
believe in.
In other words, you don't want
to go through a course like
this with a whole bunch of
things that you have to leave.
It's very nice to have some
things that you really
believe, and whether you believe
them or not, it's nice
to have theorems about them.
Even if you don't believe the
theorems, at least you have
theorems so you can fool
other people about
it, if nothing else.
Well, it turns out that L2
functions are really the right
class to look at here.
Oh, I think I left out
one of the most
important things here.
Maybe I put it down here.
No, probably not.
One of the reasons we want to
deal with L2 functions is if
you're dealing with compression,
for example, and
you take a function, if the
function has infinite energy
in it, then one of the things
that happens is that any time
you expand it into any kind of
orthonormal expansion or
orthongonal expansion, which
we'll talk about later, you
have coefficients, which
have infinite energy.
In other words, they have
infinite values, or the sum
squared of the coefficients
is equal to infinity.
When we try to compress those
we're going to find that no
matter how we do it our
mean square error
is going to be infinite.
Yes, we will talk about that
later when we get to talking
about expansions.
So for all those reasons L1
isn't the right thing, L2 is
the right thing.
A function going from the reals
into the complexes, in
other words, a complex valued
function is L2 if it's
measurable, and if this
integral is less than
infinity, in other words, if
that has finite energy.
Primarily it means it has finite
energy because all the
functions you can think
of are measurable.
So it really says you're dealing
with functions that
have finite energy here.
So, let's go on to Fourier
transforms then.
Interesting simple theorem.
I think I stated this
last time, also.
If a function is L2 and its time
limited, it's also L1.
So we've already found that if
functions are L1, they have
Fourier transforms that exist.
The reason for this is if you
square u of t, take the
magnitude squared of u of t for
any given t, it has to be
less than or equal to the
sum of u of t plus 1.
In fact, it has to be
less than that.
Why?
How would you prove this
if you had to prove it?
Well, you say gee, this is
two separate terms here.
Why don't I look at two
separate cases.
The two separate cases are
first, suppose u of t itself
as a magnitude less than 1.
If u of t has and magnitude less
than 1 and you square it,
you get something
even smaller.
So, any time u of t has a
magnitude less than 1, u
squared of t is less than
or equal to u of t.
Blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah.
If u of t --
what did I do here?
No wonder I couldn't explain
this to you.
Let's try it that way
and see if it works.
If you can prove something, turn
it around and see if you
can prove it then.
Now, two cases.
First one, let's suppose
that u of t is less
than or equal to 1.
Well then, u of t is less
And this is positive so this is
less than or equal to that.
Let's look at the other case.
u of t is greater than or
equal to 1, magnitude.
Well then, it's less
than or equal to u
of t magnitude squared.
So either way this is less
than or equal to that.
What that says is the integral
over any finite limits of u of
t dt is less than or equal
to the integral of this.
Well, the integral of this
splits up into the integral
magnitude u of t squared dt
plus the integral of 1.
Now, the integral of 1 over
any finite limits is
just b minus a.
That's where the finite
limits come in.
Finite limits say you don't have
to worry about this term
because it's finite.
So that says at any time you
have an L2 function over a
finite range, that function
is also L1
over that finite range.
Which says that any time you
take a Fourier transform of an
L2 function, which is only
non-zero over a finite range,
bingo, it's L1 and you get all
these nice properties.
It has to exist, it has to be
continuous, it has to be
bounded, and all of
that neat stuff.
So for any L2 function u of t,
what I'm going to try to do
now, and I'm just copying what
a guy by the name of
Plancherel did a
long time ago.
The thing that Plancherel did
was he said how do I know when
a Fourier transform
exists or not.
I would like to make
it exist for L2
functions, how do I do it?
Well, he said OK, the thing I'm
going to do is to take the
function u of t and I'm first
going to truncate it.
In fact, if you think in terms
of Reimann integration and
things like that, any time you
take an integral from minus
infinity to plus infinity,
what do you mean by it?
You mean the limit as you
integrate the function over
finite limits and then you let
the limits go to infinity.
So all we're doing is
the same trick here.
So we're going to take u of t,
we're going to truncate it to
some minus a to plus a over some
finite range, no matter
how big a happens to be.
We're going to call the function
b sub a of t, u of t
truncated to these limits.
In other words, u of t times a
rectangular function evaluated
at t over 2a.
Now, can all of you look at this
function and see that it
just means truncate from
minus a to plus a?
No.
Well, you should learn
to do this.
One of the ways to do it is
to say OK, the rectangular
function is defined as having
the value 1 between minus 1/2
and plus 1/2 and it's zero
everywhere else.
I think I said that before
in class, didn't I?
Certainly it's in the notes.
Rectangle ft equals 1 for
t less than or equal
to 1/2, zero else.
So with this definition you
just evaluate what happens
when t is equal to minus a, you
get rectangle of minus a
over 2a, which is minus 1/2.
When t is equal to a, you're up
to the other limit, so this
function is 1 for t between
minus a and plus a and zero
everywhere else.
Please get used to using this
and become a little facile at
sorting out what it means
because it's a very handy way
to avoid writing awkward
things like this.
So va of t by what we've said
is both L2 and its L1.
We started out with a function
which is L2 and we truncated.
Then according to this theorem
here, this function va of t is
now time limited.
It's also L2, and therefore, by
the theorem it's also L1.
Therefore, it's continue and
you can take the Fourier
transform of it -- v hat a of
f exists for all f and it's
continuous.
So this function is just the
Fourier transform that you get
when you truncate the function,
which is what you
would think of as a
way to find the
Fourier transform anyway.
I mean if this is not a
reasonable approximation to
the Fourier transform a
function, you haven't modeled
the function very well.
Because when a gets
extraordinarily large, if
there's anything of significance
that happens
before year ten to the minus 6
or which happens after year
ten to the plus 6, and you're
dealing with electronic
speeds, your models don't
make any sense.
So for anything of any interest,
these functions here
are going to start approximating
u of t, and
therefore we hope this will
start approximating the
Fourier transform of u of t.
Who can make that more
precise for me?
What happens when u of
t has finite energy?
If it has finite energy it means
that the integral of u
of t magnitude squared over the
infinite interval is finite.
So you start integrating it
over bigger and bigger
minus a to plus a.
What happens is as the minus
a to plus a gets bigger and
bigger and bigger, you're
including more and more of the
function, so that the integral
of u of t squared over that
bigger and bigger interval has
to be getting closer and
closer to the overall
integral of u of t.
Which says that the energy in u
of t minus the a of t has to
get very, very small
as a gets large.
That's one of the reasons why
we like to deal with finite
energy functions.
By definition they cannot have
a appreciable energy outside
of very large limits.
How large those large limits
have to be depends on the
function, but if you make them
large enough you will always
get negligible energy outside
of those limits.
So then we can take the Fourier
transform of this
function within those limits and
we get something which we
hope is going to be a reasonable
approximation of
the Fourier transform
of u of t.
That's what Plancherel said.
Plancherel said if we have an
L2 function, u of t, then
there is an L2 function u hat
of f, which is really the
Fourier transform of u of t.
Some people call this the
Plancherel transform of u of t
and say that indeed Plancherel
was the one that invented
Fourier transforms
or Plancherel
transforms for L2 functions.
That's probably giving him a
little too much credit, and
Fourier somewhat less
than due credit.
But it was a neat theorem.
What he said is that there is
a function u hat of f, which
we'll call the Fourier
transform, which has the
property that when you take the
integral of the difference
between u hat of f and the
transform of b sub a of t,
when you take the integral
of this dt --
in other words, when you
evaluate the energy in the
difference between u hat
of f and v sub a of f,
that goes to zero.
Well this isn't a big deal.
In other words, this is
plausible, since this integral
has to go to zero for an L2
function, that's what we just
said, then therefore, using the
energy relation, this also
has to go to zero.
So is this another example where
Plancherel just came
along at the right time and he
said something totally trivial
and became famous
because of it?
I mean as I've urged all of
you, work on problems that
other people haven't
worked on.
If you're lucky, you
will do something
trivial and become famous.
As another piece of philosophy,
you become far
more famous for doing something
trivial than for
doing something difficult,
because everybody remembers
something trivial.
And if you do something
difficult nobody even
understands it.
But no, it wasn't that because
there's something hidden here.
He says a function
like this exists.
In other words, the problem is
these functions get closer and
closer to something.
They get closer and closer to
each other as a gets bigger
and bigger.
You can show that because
you have a
handle on these functions.
Whether they get closer and
closer to a real bonafide
function or not is
another question.
Back when you studied
arithmetic, if you were in any
kind of advanced class studying
arithmetic, you
studied the rational
numbers and the
real numbers you remember.
And you remember the problem of
what happens if you take a
sequence of rational numbers
which is approaching a limit.
There's a big problem there
because when you take a
sequence of rational numbers
that approaches a limit, the
limit might not be rational.
In other words, when you take
sequences of things you can
get out of the domain of the
things you're working with.
Now, we can't get out of the
domain of being L2, but we
might get out of domain of
measurable functions, we might
get out of the domain
of functions at all.
We can have all sorts of
strange things happen.
The nice thing here, which
was really a theorem by
[? Resenage ?]
a long time ago.
It says that when you take
cosine sequences of L2
functions, they converge
to an L2 function.
So that's really what's
involved in here.
So maybe this should be called
the [? Resenage ?]
transform, I don't know.
But anyway, whatever this says,
the theorem says, the
first part of Plancherel's
theorem says that this
function exists and you get a
handle on it by taking this
transform, making a bigger and
bigger, and it says it will
converge to something in
this energy sense.
Bingo, when you're all done
this goes to zero.
We're going to denote this
function as a limit and a mean
of the Fourier transform.
In other words, we do have a
Fourier transform in the same
sense that we had a Fourier
series before.
We didn't know weather the
Fourier series would converge
at every point, but we knew that
it converged at enough
points, namely, almost
everywhere, everywhere but on
a set of measure zero.
It converges so that, in fact,
you get this kind of
relationship.
Now, do you have to
worry about that?
No.
Again, this is one of these
very nice things that says
there is a Fourier transform,
you don't have to worry about
what goes on at these oddball
sets where the function has
discountinuities and
things like that.
You can forget all of that.
You can be as careless as you've
ever been, and now you
know that it all works out
mathematically, so long as you
stick to L2 functions.
So, sticking to L2 functions
says you can be a careless
engineer, you can use lousy
mathematics and you'll always
get the right answer.
So, it's nice for engineers,
it's nice for me.
I don't like to be careful
all the time.
I like to be careful once and
then solve that and go on.
Well, because of time frequency
duality, you can do
exactly the same thing in
the frequency domain.
So, you start out defining some
b, which is bigger than
zero which is arbitrarily large,
you define a finite
bandwidth approximation as w hat
sub b of f is u hat of f.
We now know that u
hat of f exists
and it's an L2 function.
u hat of f times this
rectangular function,
that's f over 2b.
In other words, it's u hat of f
truncated to a big bandwidth
minus b to plus b.
Since w sub b of f
is L1, as well as
L2, this always exists.
So long as you deal with a
finite bandwidth, this
quantity exists.
It exists for all t and r.
It's continuous.
The second part of Plancherel's
theorem then says
that the limit as b goes to
infinity of the integral of u
of t minus this truncated
function, magnitude squared
the energy in that,
goes to zero.
This now is a little different
than what we did before.
It's easier in the sense that
we don't have to worry about
the existence of this function
because we started out with
this to start with.
It's a little harder because
we know that a function
exists, but we don't know
that it's u of t.
So, in fact, poor old Plancherel
had to do something
other than just this very simple
argument that says all
the energy works out right.
He had to also show that you
really wind up with the right
function when you get
all through with it.
But again, this is the same
kind of energy convergence
that we had before.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you discuss
non-uniqueness?
Clearly, [INAUDIBLE]
u hat f to satisfy Plancherel
1 and Plancherel 2.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in fact, any
two functions which are L2
equivalent.
But you see the nice thing is
when you take this finite
bandwidth approximation
there's only one.
It's only when you get
to the limit that all
of this mess occurs.
If you take these different
possible functions, u hat of
f, which just differ in these
negligible sets of measure
zero, those don't affect
this integral.
Sets of measure zero don't
affect integrals at all.
So the mathematicians deal
with L2 theory by talking
about equivalence classes
of functions.
I find it hard to think about
equivalence classes of
functions and partitioning the
set of all functions into a
bunch of equivalence classes.
So I just sort of remember in
the back of my mind that there
are all these functions which
differ in a strange way.
We'll talk about that more when
we get to the sampling
theorem later today,
because there it
happens to be important.
Here it's not really important,
here we don't have
to worry about it.
Anyway, we can always get back
to the u of t that we started
with in this way.
Now, this says that all L2
functions have Fourier
transforms in this
very nice sense.
In other words, at this point
you don't have to worry about
continuity, you don't have to
worry about how fast things
drop off, you don't have to
worry about anything.
So long as you have finite
energy functions, this
beautiful result always
holds true.
There always is a Fourier
transform, it always has this
nice property that it has the
same energy as the function
you started with.
The only nasty thing, as Dave
pointed out, is that, in fact,
it might not be a unique
function, but it's close
enough to unique.
It's unique in an engineering
sense.
The other thing is that L2 wave
forms don't include some
of your favorite wave forms.
They don't include constants,
they don't include sine waves,
and they don't include Dirac
impulse functions.
All of them have infinite
energy.
I pointed out in class, spent
quite a bit of time explaining
why an impulse function had
infinite energy by looking at
it as a very narrow pulse of
width epsilon and a height 1
over epsilon, and showing that
the energy in that is 1 over
epsilon, and as epsilon goes
to zero and the pulse gets
narrower and narrower, bingo,
the energy goes to infinity.
Constants are the same way, they
extend on and on forever.
Therefore, they have infinite
energy, except if the constant
happens to be zero.
Sine waves are the same way,
they dribble on forever.
So the question is are these
good models of reality?
The answer is they're good for
some things and they're very
bad for other things.
The point in this course is
that if you're looking for
wave forms that are good models
for either the kinds of
functions that we're going to
quantize, namely, source wave
forms, or if you're looking for
the kinds of things that
we're going to transmit
on channels, these
are very lousy functions.
They don't make any sense in
a communication context.
But anyway, where did these
things come from?
Constants and sine waves
result from refusing to
explicitly model when very
long-lasting functions terminate.
In other words, if you're
looking at a carrier function
in a communication's system,
sine of 2 pi, f carrier times
t, it just keeps on wiggling
around forever.
Since you want to talk about
that over the complete time of
interest, you don't want to say
what the time of interest
is, you don't want to admit to
your employer that this thing
is going to stop working after
one month because you want to
let him think that he's going
to make a profit off of this
forever, and you don't want to
commit to putting it into use
in one month when you know it's
going to get delayed for
a whole year.
So you want to think of this as
something which is permanent.
You don't want to answer the
question at what time does it
start and at what time does it
end, because for many of the
questions you ask, you
can just regard
it as going on forever.
You have the same thing
with impulses.
Impulses are always models
of short pulses.
If you put these short pulses
through a filter, the only
thing which is of interest
in them is what
their integral is.
And since the only thing of
interest is their integral,
you call it an impulse and you
don't worry about just how
narrow it is, except that it
has infinite energy and,
therefore, whenever you start
to deal with a situation in
which energy is important, these
becomes lousy models.
So we can't use these
when we're
talking about L2 functions.
That's the price we pay for
dealing with L2 functions.
But it's a small price because
for almost all the things
we'll be dealing with, it's the
energy of the functions
that are really important.
So as communication wave forms,
infinite energy wave
forms make mean square error
quantization results
meaningless.
In other words, when you sample
these infinite energy
wave forms you get results that
don't make any sense, and
they make those channel
results meaningless.
Therefore, from now on, whether
I remember to say it
or not, everything we deal with,
unless we're looking at
counter examples to something,
is going to be an L2 function.
Let's go on.
I'm starting to feel like I'm
back in our signals and
systems course, because at this
point I'm defining my
third different kind
of transform.
Fortunately, this is the last
transform we will have to talk
about, so we're all
done with this.
The other nice thing is that
the discrete time Fourier
transform happens to be just the
time frequency dual of the
Fourier series.
So that whether you've ever
studied the dtft or not, you
already know everything there
is to know about it, because
the only things there are to
know about it are the results
about Fourier series.
So the theorem is really the
same theorem that we had for
Fourier series.
Assume that you have a function
of frequency, u hat
of f -- before we had a function
of time, now we have
a function of frequency.
Suppose it's defined over
the interval minus w
to plus w into c.
In other words, a way we often
say that a function is
truncated is to say it goes
from some interval into c.
This is a complex function which
is non-zero only for f
in this finite bandwidth
range.
We want to assume that this
is L2 and thus, we
know it's also L1.
Then we're going to take the
Fourier coefficients.
Before we thought of the
Fourier coefficients as
corresponding to what goes on at
different frequencies, now
we're going to regard them as
time quantities, and we'll see
exactly why later.
So we'll define these
as the Fourier
coefficients of this function.
So they're 1 over 2w times
this integral here.
You remember before when we
dealt with the Fourier series,
we went from minus t over
2 to plus t over 2.
Now we're going from
minus w to plus w.
Why?
It's just convention, there's
no real reason.
So that what's happening here
is that this is a Fourier
series formula for a coefficient
where we're
substituting w for t over 2.
We're putting a plus sign in
the exponent instead of a
minus sign.
In other words, we're doing this
hermitian duality bit.
What's the other difference?
We're interchanging time
and frequency.
Aside from that it's exactly
the same theorem that we
established -- well, that
we stated before.
So we know that this quantity
here, since u hat of f is L1,
this is finite and it exists
-- that's just a finite
complex number and nothing more
-- for all integer k.
Also, the convergence result
when we go back, this is the
formula we try to use to go
back to the function we
started with.
It's just a finite
approximation
to the Fourier series.
We're saying that as k zero gets
larger and larger, this
finite approximation approaches
the function in
energy sense.
So this is exactly what you
should mean by a Fourier
series anyway.
It's exactly what you
should mean by a
Fourier transform anyway.
As you go to the limit with more
and more terms you get
something which is equal to what
you started with, except
on the set of measure zero.
In other words, it converges
everywhere where it matters.
It converges to something
in the sense that the
energy is the same.
I said that in such a way that
makes it a little simpler than
it really is.
You can't always say that this
converges in any nice way.
Next time I'm going to show
you a truly awful function
which we'll use in the Fourier
series instead of dtft, which
is time limited and which is
just incredibly messy and
it'll show you why you have to
be a little bit careful about
stating these results.
But you don't have to worry
about it most of the time,
because this theorem
is still true.
It's just that you have to be a
little careful about how to
interpret it because you don't
know whether this is going to
reach a limit or not.
All you know is that this will
be true, this energy
difference goes to zero.
Also, the energy in the function
is equal to the
energy in the coefficients.
This was the thing that we
found so useful with the
Fourier series.
It's why we can play this game
that we play with mean square
quantization error of taking a
function and then turning it
into a sequence of samples,
trying to quantize the samples
for minimum mean square error
and associate the mean square
error in the samples with
the mean square
error on the function.
You can't do that with anything
that I know of other
than mean square error.
If you want to deal with other
kinds of quantization errors,
you have a real problem
going from
coefficients to functions.
And finally, for any set of
numbers u sub k, if the sum is
less than infinity, in other
words, if you're dealing with
a sequence of finite energy,
there always is such a
frequency function.
Many people when they use the
discrete time Fourier
transform think of starting with
the sequence and taking a
sequence and saying well it's
nice to think of this sequence
in the frequency domain, and
then they say a function f
exists such that this is true,
or they just say that this is
equal to that without worrying
about the convergence at all,
which is more common.
But since we've already gone
through all of this for the
Fourier series, we might as well
say it right here also.
So there's really nothing
different here.
But now the question is why
do these u of k's --
I mean why do we think of those
as time coefficients?
I mean what's really going
on in this discrete
time Fourier transform.
At this point it just looks like
a lot of mathematics and
it's hard to interpret what
any of these things mean.
Well, the next thing I want
to do is to go into
the sampling theorem.
The sampling theorem, in fact,
is going to interpret for you
what this discrete time Fourier
transform is, because
the sampling theorem and the
discrete time Fourier
transform are just intimately
related, they're hand and
glove with each other,
and that's the next
thing we want to do.
But first we have to re-write
this a little bit.
We're going to say that this
frequency function is the
limit in the mean of this --
this rectangular function is
what we use just to make sure
we're only talking about
frequency between
minus w and plus w.
The limit in the mean, there's a
little notational trick that
we use so that we can think of
this as just a limit instead
of thinking of it as this
crazy thing that we just
derive, which is really
not so crazy.
That means we can talk about
this transform without always
rubbing our noses in all
of this mess here.
It just means that once in
awhile we go back and think
what does this really mean.
It means convergence in energy
rather than convergence
point-wise, because we might
not have convergence
point-wise.
So we're going to write this
also as the limit in the mean
of the sum over k of u of k.
We're going to glop all
of this together.
This is just some function
of k and a frequency.
So we're going to call that phi
sub k of f at some wave
form, and the wave
form is this.
What happens if you look at the
relationship between to
phi k of f and phi
k prime of f?
Namely, if you look at two
different functions.
These two functions are
orthongonal to each other for
the same reason that the
functions that the sinusoid
you used in the Fourier series
are orthongonal.
Namely, you take this function,
you multiply it by e
to the minus 2 pi ik prime
f over 2w times
this rectangular function.
You integrate from minus w
to w and what do you get?
You're just integrating
a sinusoid --
the whole thing is one
big sinusoid --
over one period of that sinusoid
or multiple periods
of the sinusoid.
Actually, k minus k prime
periods of the sinusoid.
And when you integrate a
sinusoid over a period, what
do you get?
You get zero.
So it says that these functions
are all orthongonal
to each other.
So, presto, we have another
orthongonal expansion just
like the Fourier series gave us
an orthongonal expansion.
And in fact, it's the same
orthongonal expansion.
Now the next thing to observe
is that we have done the
Fourier transform and we've also
done the discrete time
Fourier transform.
In both of them we're dealing
with some frequency function.
Now we're dealing with some
frequency function which is
limited to minus w to plus
w, but we have two
expansions for it.
We have the Fourier transform,
so we can go to a function u
of t, and we also have
this discrete
time Fourier transform.
So u of t is equal to this
Fourier transform here.
Again, I should write limit in
the mean here, but then I
think about and I say
do I have to write
limit in the mean?
No.
I don't need a limit in the
mean here because I'm
integrating this over
finite limits.
Since I'm taking a function over
finite limits, u hat of f
is over these limits, is an L1
function, therefore, this
integral exists.
This function is a continuous
function.
There aren't any sets of measure
zero involved here.
This is one specific function
which is always the same.
You know what it is exactly
at every point.
At every point t,
this converges.
So then what we're going to do,
what the sampling theorem
does is it relates this to
what you get with a dtft.
So the sampling theorem says
let u hat of f be an L2
function which goes from minus
ww to c, and let u of t be
this, namely, that, which we
now know exists and is
continuous.
Define capital T as 1 over 2w.
You don't have to do that if you
don't want to, but it's a
little easier to think in terms
of some increment of
time, T, here.
Then u of t is continuous,
L2 and bounded.
It's bounded by u of t less
than or equal to this.
Why is that?
It doesn't make any sense
as I stated it.
Now it makes sense.
OK, its magnitude is bounded.
Its magnitude is bounded because
if you take u of t
magnitude, it's equal to the
magnitude of this which is
less than or equal to the
integral of the magnitude of
this, which is equal to the
just u hat of f, which
is what we have here.
So all of that works nicely.
So, u of t is a nice,
well-defined function.
Then the other part of it is
that u of t is equal to the
sum if its values at these
sample points times sinc of t
minus kt over t.
Now you've probably seen this
sampling theorem before.
How many people haven't
seen this before?
I mean aside from the question
of trying to do it --
do it in a way that
makes sense.
OK, you've all seen it.
So good.
What it's saying is you can
represent a function in terms
of just knowing what
its samples are.
Or you can take the function,
you can sample it, and when
you sample it if you put these
little sinc hats around all
the samples, you get back
to the function again.
So you take all the samples,
you then put these sincs
around them, add them
all up, and
bingo, you got the function.
Let's see why that's true.
Here's the sinc function here.
The important thing about sinc
t, sine pi t over pi t, which
you can see by just looking at
the sine function, is it has
the value 1 when t
is equal to zero.
I mean to get that value 1, you
really have to go through
a limiting operation here to
think of sine pi t when t is
very small as being
approximately equal to pi t.
When you divide pi t by pi t you
get 1, so that's its value
there and value around there.
At every other sample point,
namely, at t equals 1, sine of
pi t is zero.
At t equals 2, sine of pi
t is equal to zero.
So the sinc function is 1 at
zero and is zero at every
other integer point.
Now to see why it's true and to
understand what the dtft is
all about, note that we have
said that a frequency
function, u hat of f, can be
expressed as the sum over k --
and I should use a limit in the
mean here but I'm not --
of uk times this transform
relationship here.
Well, these are these functions
that we talked about
awhile ago.
They're these functions.
They're the sinusoids, periodic
sinusoids in k
truncated in frequency.
So we know that u hat of f is
equal to that dtft expansion.
If I take the inverse Fourier
transform of that, I can take
the inverse Fourier transform
of all these functions and
I'll get u of t is equal to the
sum over k, of uk pk of t.
I'm being careless about
the mathematics here.
I've been careful about
it all along.
The notes does it carefully,
particularly in the appendix.
I'm not going to worry
about that here.
If I take the function pk of
f, which is this truncated
sinusoid, and I take the inverse
transform of that --
take the transform of
this, I get this.
Can you see that just
by inspection?
If you were really hot on these
things, if you just
finished taking 6.003, you could
probably see that by
inspection.
If you remember all of those
relationships that we went
through before, you can
see it by inspection.
The Fourier transform of erect
function is a sinc function.
This exponential here when you
go into the time domain
corresponds to a time shift,
so that gives rise to this
time shift here.
The 1 over t is just one of
these constants you have to
keep straight, and which I would
do just by integrating
the things to see what I get.
Finally, u of kt, if I look at
this, is just 1 over t times u
of k, because these functions
here are these sinc functions,
which are zero everywhere
but on their own point.
So if I look at u of kt, it's a
sum over k of ck of kt, and
ck of kt is only 1 when little
t is equal to k times capital
T, and therefore, I get
that point there.
Therefore, u of kt is just
1 over t times u of k.
That finishes the sampling
theorem except for really
tracing through all of these
things about convergence, but
it also tells you what the
discrete time Fourier
transform is.
Because the discrete time
Fourier transform is just
scaled samples of u of t.
In other words, you start out
with this frequency function,
you take the inverse Fourier
transform of it, you get a
time function.
You take the samples of that,
you scale them, and those are
the coefficients in the
discrete time Fourier
transform, which is what you
use discrete time Fourier
transforms for.
You think of sampling of
function, then you represent
the function in terms of those
samples and then you want to
go into the frequency domain as
a way of dealing with the
properties of those samples, and
all you're doing is just
going into the Fourier transform
of u of t, and all
of that works out.
There's one bizarre thing here,
and I'm going to talk
about that more next time.
That is that when you look at
this time frequency limited
function, u hat of f, u hat of
f can be very badly behaved.
You can have a frequency limited
function which does
all sorts of crazy things.
Since it's frequency limited
as inverse transform, it's
beautifully behaved.
It's just the sum of sinc
functions -- it's bounded,
it's continuous and
everything else.
When we go back into the
frequency domain it is just as
ugly as can be.
So what we have in the sampling
theorem, it comes out
particularly clearly.
Is that L1 functions in one
domain are nice, continuous,
beautiful functions which are
not L1 in the other domain.
So you sort of go from
L1 to continuous.
Now when we're dealing with
L2 functions, they're not
continuous, they're not anything
else, but you always
go from L2 to L2.
In other words, you can't get
out of the L2 domain, and
therefore, when you're dealing
with L2 functions, all you
have to worry about is L2
functions, because you always
stay there no matter what.
When we start talking about
stochastic processes, we'll
find out you always
stay there also.
In other words, you only have
to know about one thing.
We've seen here that to
interpret what these Fourier
transforms mean, it's nice to
have a little idea about L1
functions also because when we
think of going to the limit,
when we go to the limit we get
something which is badly
behaved, and for these finite
time and finite frequency
approximations, we have things
which are beautifully behaved.
I'm going to stop now so we
can pass out the quizzes.